- All right we've had
a lot of fun this hour,
but before we say goodbye.
I have one more amazing story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
School drop off lines,
nobody likes 'em including me.
They're a daily frustration
for most parents
especially when the car in front of you
decides to take their sweet ol' time
and apparently has
nothing to do afterwards.
We've all been there.
It's why so many people
appreciate this video
from a Texas mom.
Of course, it's a Texas mom.
Think of this as like a PSA
for dropping off your kids.
Check it out.
- [Texas mom] All right y'all.
I'm tired. It's been
the third week of school
and people still don't understand
how to pick up drop off line goes.
So I'm gonna help y'all. All right.
First thing first, put your kids
on the passenger side
of the car. All right.
If you got multiple of them,
teach them how to one two step on out
slide, shuffle, whatever you gotta do.
Get 'em out the car.
They should have their
backpacks on in the car.
It's okay. It's working on they posture.
Let 'em sit up. They
need to be ready to go.
We are yielding. It's not a stop.
It's a yield. We already
going five miles per hour.
We gonna reduce that
thing down to about three
but we not coming down to zero.
We gonna teach them how to tuck and roll.
(Kelly laughs)
- I love it. We have that mom on the line
right now say hi to Lateasha
watching on NBC 5 Dallas Fort worth.
Oh my gosh.
You don't know how many times I have said
tuck and roll to my children
and my car dropping them off.
So you said that right?
Tuck n roll at the end, right?
- Yes. Ma'am you heard me correct?
Tuck n roll is exactly what I said.
(laughs)
- I'm with you. It is.
I literally dropped my
kids off this morning
and sometimes it's just
like, oh my God, do you?
So you're just going home after this.
Like, you're not doing anything else
after the what's happening.
So Lateasha's boys, Jeremiah and Jason
made their own video for us as well.
I want y'all to see this. Check it out.
- [Jeremiah And Jason] Hi Kelly.
We gonna teach you, teach
you how to tuck n roll.
First what you do is sit
on the passenger side.
- If you are in the
back make sure you know
how to one two step out the car.
- Don't open your door
until the car stops.
- Car stops we tuck n roll.
(Kelly laughs)
- That is how it's done.
That is how good you have taught your
I do the same thing with my children.
I'm like get out.
I was like, people are in line.
That's amazing.
Thank you so much, Lateasha.
You are so funny.
I love that you are representing
Texas women so well.
I'm liking your post right now.
I love Jason and Jeremiah as well.
And that's not all our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of FriXion
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show.
Want to celebrate mama's who are providing
public service announcements,
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000 just for doing this.
(crowd applauds)
(Lateasha laughs)
- Thank you guys so much.
We definitely appreciate
it. We love you guys.
And remember tuck n roll,
get on out the line.
- Get out of the car. We got places to go.
Oh my gosh. Thank you so much.